for national democrats complete this
sentence for me your recall victory
means that we need to stiffen our spines
and lean in
to keeping people safe and healthy
that we shouldn't be timid
in trying to protect people's lives
and mitigate the spread
and transmission of this disease
that it's the right thing to do
but it's also a motivating factor in
this election
this is an off year off month election
and the turnout
was off the charts because people were
motivated because they understood what
was at stake the consequences were that
clear and democrats i hope are paying
attention do national democrats have a
timidity problem
this has been hard
look i was recalled
no small degree because of our approach
to this pandemic and so what i'm saying
here is be affirmative
don't be timid lean in because at the
end of the day it's not just about the
formal authority of setting the tone and
tenor on max
on vaccines and mass but it's the moral
authority that we have that we're on the
right side of history and we're doing
the right thing to save people's lives